it boris johnson in 2019 pouring  concrete into fracking wells in the uk  as a virtue signal to how they were  going to be committed to net zero  climate goals  50 years of natural gas from these wells  poured cement over  now what happened during the 10 years  radical increase in reliance on  russian energy and that included germany  or some some countries i think germany  is 40 near 50  all of europe is like 38 39 near 40  their reliance on vladimir putin's  russia why is russia able to do all this  because they're not following the  dictates of the united nations of they  don't have a domestic green new deal you  don't see putin putin will pay lip  service as needed but it has been the  greatest boon to russian aggression  russian national interest